alrighty guys wait are playing the
walking dead season dos dos the [ __ ] is
this no sorry okay well here goes the
first one and six hundred days or four
days was amazing so that's this
oh geez import boss sick okay built off
you know about you search yes let's
[ __ ] do this I think they're like
once a foul right yeah ooh see me good
that is gonna be good previously hey
there how they grabbed a drink I'm
who've been oh hi yourself the Rings
ring yes yes I know who you are and I
know you're a killer oh ok back then do
you have to kill those men yes yes hey
bet I did I hope you know what you're
doing with her I can't get Molly said
Crawford is the only place left in
Savannah that still has people that
could [ __ ] up in the end it means it
must be where my mom and dad are gonna I
think it'd be safer for you to stay here
with obi Clementine clip it time [ __ ]
[ __ ] the rabies I know how to be a dad
you know she wouldn't be exposed to what
she has been with you
we I so my parents and I chain her up
you can come with me set the hood right
ear honey I love honey it's okay don't
meet Kristen okay
yeah he was pretty good dude I took his
arm not that actually affected I hmm ok
ok here we go guys here he goes now the
walking dead dad they'd how he knows how
you say
no content or placer everything else I'd
like that what do you think only you
can't be serious I am we are not doing
that why not because thanks don't come
on Krista what's wrong with you'll need
we're not calling our baby you'll need
one of you is enough Clementine a little
help here Oh me the second no owe me
junior know what if it's a girl then we
neighbor Krista but I'm Krista I don't
want to call her Kristin that's just
confused anymore Genevieve I don't care
how do not be like our piece I'm not
dare efficient take a shower I take
everything seriously especially the low
meets future keep talking and you'll be
sleeping in the ring tonight oh [ __ ]
remember that time in Barstow Vegas
weekend sorry why don't you get cleaned
up with a girl's room clam I hope the
safe works in there what's down on it
just be careful and make sure to keep
track of your things we'll be right next
door okay I like wouldn't use bathroom
to them or they're just dangerous and
smelly and no running water is it was
like outside for somewhere else yeah
didn't change the whole thing someone
had the shets oh yeah it was Jennifer
re-grout saying I like his s okay why
don't she's [ __ ] answer so much [ __ ]
out of bear I look familiar she must be
in here then what the [ __ ] will she go
you should get on birth see some pop at
first there's gonna be some pop at heart
safety get cleaned up
hmm Oh God God caddies I could chef a
pillow oh no maybe a zombie there no is
there just like [ __ ] in there anything
this all right came in a little left on
right it's your [ __ ] zombie there now
ok
can I cast votes Alabama oh [ __ ] oh shut
[ __ ] this [ __ ] out it's [ __ ] ain't
playin no more she'll do a nasty [ __ ]
she gonna take a [ __ ] in chi and I could
tell by her gait that's gonna be [ __ ]
disgusting all just ready Oh sheer
upland my back open the gun oh [ __ ] I
gotta kill her immediately cowers I made
[ __ ]
it sucks i have their [ __ ] too [ __ ] i
see you oh how dear you're not fooling
me that's my gun smile now give it back
wash it up get out here we have two
attacker we got to attack her [ __ ] I
don't need you got anything on you well
ten pounds come on let's see you don't
have to do this it's mean you've got to
be mean to keep going out here I'm not
mean yeah and who got your gun I'm
serious what else you got that's it
don't lie to me up top oh she's bagent
pop give me what you got I'm not
screwing around come on I don't have
anything give me that hat no where'd you
get it huh I asked you a question my dad
gave it to me just give it to me tennis
[ __ ] down
Jeong Jeong Jeong look at all this junk
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] in more [ __ ] why you
ain't got nothing good I like the last
people like that they had all kinds of
this [ __ ] that was a good catch Oh me
help my life you ain't nothing you're
just a little wrestle her you gonna cry
little fish this your daddy what a close
up um did you chat wow that was
startlingly fast Jesus I didn't need to
I didn't mean to I didn't mean oh good
get cut ken what if I was a lot like of
that that well I tennis team me oh he's
like that's just something baby evade
yeah I guess they're stylish shut off
hardcore okay aunt Sonia it's fine she's
gonna realize say 16 months later so
there's a kid in the picture right it'll
need [ __ ] I'm not good to get these days
not luck and these to get these days
don't get the baby [ __ ] up
camera found Krista oh that like train
thing this will never work look at this
is pathetic the woods do wet to burn so
we smoke the flame it's okay I can wait
only do is wait and for what you should
be doing this not me tending a fire so
you can cook and stay warm it's
something you have to be able to do
Clementine otherwise oh she's so skinny
I'm gonna say other people we need to
find a group people we can trust he's
been on our own for too long trust you
think you can trust someone out here not
now not anymore did you cray cray I'm
freezing you think this is bad wait till
we get up to Wellington then talk to me
about cold or if we make it [ __ ] go
down south we still have a couple hard
months ahead of us this rain will turn
to sleet then ice then snow it won't be
easy hmm be better there right safer
maybe so they say it has to be I know it
will we'll see we just need to keep
moving north mhm okay
sounds like a [ __ ] shoes I'm gonna go
look for more would you just keep the
fire aight aight no chance Jesus with
the obvious so I would like free that
here that is messed up they did their
kid that's messed up screech I really
lost it like Jesus
ah
you cannot burn that
cinnamon picture no I were this lighter
sad [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] hurt their sad
mm-hmm blend up let that baby oh yeah
well it's crazy better but still not
enough the flames are too low cuz I'm
little kimble you know get some sticks
okay okay okay this won't burn okay good
again passed your first test and passed
your first test torn jacket this will
never burn it's too wet there any that
Jesus that's gonna be
this might bird yeah it's just like I'm
gonna rain SS
[ __ ] tits on the way and I'm of
Chiefs s brother trolley I need your
marbles people are
hey bran that pickle a okay chris is
about to get shot
krista is about to get capped where's
the rest of your group I'm by myself
well she's lying cut the [ __ ] lady it
it's just me sneak ahead you let your
fool [ __ ]
[ __ ] John Lee
get the [ __ ] over here now Mauti your
girl I'm not [ __ ] around that's right
over here
yeah like this before it actually sad
that [ __ ] oh you gotta be kidding me
oh good nutritious
oh yeah good
love Santa like a pressing key and
pressing Q oh yeah yeah yeah get it
right back Kenna
yesh this is getting hey just get a real
crack yeah nice fresh char that's what
this season needed a fresh start you
know
lil be so proud of ya
hmm
okay know that
huh
soon he was really nice for being like a
weird graphic novel stuff it takes some
we're happy between the comics and like
the show
and I should have brain that pic jelly
first up are you there I can't stay
[ __ ] there looking around looking
around and I kissed her goodbye you know
right now to get dental record you know
how far she flowed down I'm sorry
that space bar did it let us check at
the angles Oh Oh exact wormans warning
sign like there's like loose chickens
here snakes and bears and bear snakes no
notorious [ __ ] bear stick right now
hmm
okay we are [ __ ] beyond comprehension
oh [ __ ] what is that the bear snake seen
this before
Oh
close the Jaguar what's a dog well [ __ ]
yeah sir Sam it's okay boy yeah yeah
[ __ ] penny bad afternoon okay you don't
like that got it sorry yeah hey dispatch
what's he doing he's leading us out of
here yep very courageous hey would you
find boy yeah where are you going wait
up
no oh good like this guy uh he wants us
to kill no it's also sastre not just
about yes boy who looks pretty run over
but you never know let's look around for
some food Thank spaghetti others happen
for dogs fiery to ya ok ok search the
van
yeah pentatonic it looks like they were
a happy family once I hope they left
some food behind somewhere
well the panel's got to be here right
she's got a shout out to us hmm nothing
edible you know
um let me throw that little disk guess
whose frisbee Hey Oh what is it you want
to play catch oh very nice and
responsive oh oh good boy good boy okay
get back get get get I've earned his
chest and his respect boy good boy let's
check it out can't throw it again can I
that beard empty better keep looking boy
your can you won't drink that did you
like 10
it's not much of a tense anymore by that
scavengers tore it apart think anyone's
been sleeping in here I can't tell maybe
we'd better not wait around to find out
okay what's her right here what's over
here yeah oh oh hey boy what's the
matter huh no well we have to be quiet
I am so sick of that smell he'll um okay
it's okay he's dead okay daddy i can see
the bike looks like he tried to cut it
out but that never works ever hey man
we're smart he's not are smarter than
all of them yeah I'm all right Lisa that
no we gotta grab that they did just God
hey it's okay boy he can't hurt us
think he had himself tied up or did
someone force him to do this
hmm that looks like it hurt don't kill
this for keep still let's say I'd say
dance Oh silly me stand back okay target
hundred whack [ __ ]
Oh
oh yeah yeah I gotta get out yet again
he's not like his not like that again I
get again he's not doing too hot make
one more time see we just have to stay
out of their reach music okay we're in
something today thank you get that knife
real quick good good
oh cuz we don't lick the blade I like
that is so badass it not yet snow pretty
sure at least we found something useful
we won't go another night without food
okay sheth asserts the pockets like no
up cans everything now can I
that's what though no food here either
well here we go won't you dump it that's
disgusting I'm rapping yeah oh my god
thank you he's like hey they can huh
let's see what's inside
please don't be bad ok ok ok ok and that
ok thank God and I for your ma they're
like I guess you are pretty hungry too
my fate is that nothing I had fun with
that hey here you go hey
okay okay and do not expect that um that
is insanely traumatic ok ok that is
shockingly graphic Jesus sorry
yeah yeah member that
let sucked out all right it's just going
to be a lot more intense to say than I
guess when I just ate that you're going
to cut that
I get some beans dad like what the heck
you down
and middle of camp counters at rocks
mm-hmm
so far a lot has happened ghirardelli de
cristo which i had to do in season one
failed the whole season but I got rid of
them so happy ok me is it accurate great
yes [ __ ] and this [ __ ] and I came
Romans Eddie got I can't move it
is that okay yeah I like to sniff crowd
I'm out grabber let's go come on kid we
got a kid finalizing capable people
you
I think I think we're safe yeah yeah
we're good hey you all right I can say
anything never they think I'm [ __ ] out
okay I'll take that as a no good what
are you doing out here where the people
you with there's no chance you made it
this long on your own I don't want them
thinking we're doing anything but trying
to help you I'm alone everyone I know is
gone it's just me now I'm sorry to hear
that hmm i just lost a sister we've all
lost folks uh-huh well I'm Luke this is
Pete hey there hi I'm Clementine it's
nice to meet you clone of time but for
now we're gonna take you back to our
group and we got a doctor with us and
you look like you could use some ocean
what what is it she's she's a bit man
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what are we gonna do
here no it was a dog I didn't see any
dog Clementine come on kid we just saw
you with those lurkers man look at it no
no just look at it please yeah and have
you sink your teeth into Pete's neck no
dinner our mother one cuz I don't know a
dog bite from a mosquito bite from a
lurker bite man it's not
yeah blood hmm all right let's see oh
hey watch yourself I don't look at me
like that you're the one that's bit here
okay ouch see he's it uh select she says
well could be a dog I'm sorry [ __ ] so
where this dog go the one that did this
no what what does that matter Pete
seriously I I killed it what really a
dog shows up and bites you and you just
kill it what would you have done I don't
know it attacked me still you don't you
don't kill dog yeah I'm into that
Clementine Hank all that yes you telling
us the truth yeah then you look me in
the eyes when you answer yes
alright Clementine that's good enough
for me what else was she gonna say I've
got a good [ __ ] detector Luke that's
why you can never beat me at poker she's
always ready yet all right how can you
be sure well I'm sure I ain't willing to
leave a little girl in the woods to die
when we got a doctor with us that can
make a call we could have Carlos take a
look at it first they ain't gonna like
this not with what have you don't have
to remind me of that boy right our
sounds so cool come on
oh really nice house Jesus Clementine
are you feeling all right I'm fine just
tired well you better be fine cuz i
ain't carrying you anymore with that
bite on your arm don't worry well [ __ ]